a follow-up question from dusty green is
robin hood etcetera allowing repeal
retail people to buy into specs now
adding fuel to the fire okay spax are
public you can buy them on any platform
so
i think that that's independent of robin
and what you might be referring to here
is robin hood giving access to ipos
at the ipo price with equal footing and
i think that doesn't apply to spax which
come out at ten dollars always i think
as the tradition is and then they go
find something to buy so i think spax
don't work that way so you're talking
about the early access program that's to
make it possible for you to buy uber or
airbnb at the price they went public at
just like the insiders at goldman sachs
or high net worth individuals were able
to so kind of two different things i do
think ultimately
um people are getting educated and what
we're seeing here in the market is uh
just a really big education for people
who are placing bets i believe people
should be allowed to place bats i
believe the best way to learn how to not
lose money is to lose some money doing
stupid stuff so if you bought nikola if
you bought you know
whatever company that collapsed uh
because they didn't have a real product
and you took a leap of faith well guess
what now you're in my business
i take leaps of faith every day
investing in
very little traction and now the public
can do it too am i gonna tell you you
can't do it you're too stupid no i'm
gonna tell you be careful make it a
small percentage of your net worth i
would say one to five percent uh maybe
one to ten percent for highly
speculative investments
why would you make it 10 or less why
would i advise that you keep highly
speculative investments to 10 or less of
your portfolio i would do that because
if you lost it all which is a
possibility you're not going to miss it
right it's only percent you can make it
back if you're doing seven percent a
year in just over a year
so keep that in mind folks be careful
out there for every
really highly speculative investment you
make maybe you make four five six seven
eight nine ten
[Music]
safer bets and have some diversification
your portfolio seems to be the best
advice in the financial world is to be
diversified not concentrated if you want
to have outlier results sure be
concentrated but understand that's like
going to the you know
roulette table and just betting it all
on black and like okay you know see what
happens could be dangerous